[Music]
and despite the trollsnews no no come on
now you know I like blacks next video
patrols submitted by creeping on David
nice try dude I'm already creeping on
you first and I am already Samir mail
this cake baker is helping Internet
users get revenge on trolls how oh come
on sending them cake they don't know
what the [ __ ] they're doing the tools
are gonna eat these people alive yeah
it's prank cakes no trust me on this I
can't wait to hear this game because
it's all evil all over a cake and it
[ __ ] explodes in their face with acid
it still look glitter that'd be pretty
cool that would be it's all those are
the people by the way who don't take all
this [ __ ] so seriously so the cake
person is being of course like oh we're
gonna do something about this and
they're doomed from the outset or what
are your thoughts on the trolls I just
deliberately want to hurt people look I
maybe that's trolling then that's like
it depends right every swelling has
humour and it's funny I exactly there's
a line that it can cross where it's like
I'm just an [ __ ] we're just talking
[ __ ] yeah exactly
Joy's pissing people off that like take
themselves too seriously
it takes some a bunch of [ __ ] way too
seriously exactly like a cake maker it's
not wait for this [ __ ]
this cake maker cake maker so cats she
owns this bakery called troll cakes
where yeah the whole business is around
troll in it you so she thinks that the
trolls are gonna fall for a cake called
troll cake so she does it's like they're
named my company is prank cakes
you'll never expect it the trolls aren't
buying it I think people are buying it
for the trolling yeah but you got a cake
delivered to you from and now did you
walk on it then you want unless the cake
tastes like [ __ ] no well apparently the
cakes are edible and they're really
delicious so she says Wow okay
the hell it sent me some troll pizza you
know I would love that [ __ ] it's amazing
it's like rubber but free those cakes
that don't look like cakes they look
like she does she's a pile of [ __ ] cuz
this is really funny cuz I'm gonna read
this cake right it just says [ __ ] you
you terrible ass Hume I hope you [ __ ]
die and as I'm reading I'm slicing it to
it somebody's over you're all gonna go
to someone's YouTube channel and talk
[ __ ] around all day what do they expect
the trolls to be like that encourage
them even giving them points yeah so she
her prices range from thirty to sixty
dollars for a cake yeah for a cake so
Dale [ __ ] wedding is because so the
most expensive option is when she
actually needs to track down where this
troll lives or like where she can be
then this can do that so apparently she
can do that I will pay for that service
that's like what that service so I could
find the person yeah yeah I don't send
them a cake yeah the Macchio is gonna
start using the service [ __ ] so this is
cat yeah I mean hey you look like she
talks like what are you doing trying to
get a cake they're gonna get a cake what
are you trying to get some brownie sent
to your [ __ ] door exactly exactly no
I certainly need a highly offensive yes
angel justice is the only thing that we
have anymore
try not talking with the overbite that
that means any I want a cake to Romy you
all were getting cake I want this
encourages trolling because everyone
give me a slice of y'all cake
why does it look so like it's just like
so dramatic it's like as a matter of
fact like that's the Sheep they caught
it like in the
of saying something and they made her
look this is what you get this is what
you get I was trying to tell you I was
trying to warn you here her cake she's
in the middle sing [ __ ]
so she'll send a cake that says and in
such a screenshot of that person's
comment or the troll
so presented Instagram or Facebook this
one I think it's Facebook so it says the
cake is about me not you Andrew and I so
the card says congratulations your
internet comment has been made into a
chocolate chip brownie troll cake yum
and then so that she actually put the
the comment on the cake can you resell
this [ __ ] wait there's a there's a catch
you tell the Internet resell brownies
like there's a cake end up tasting
really bad or like what's good or maybe
she has to say that she's you know what
she's a Care Bear that's very uh what's
it called Gandhi like right like a man
comes and spits in your face and instead
you give him five bucks right exactly
yeah but a man didn't murder all your
family members yeah I'm saying I think
that's what she's doing
it's like if you show this person the
right way they will stop murdering and
killing yeah they think everyone's like
you and that's the mistake so many
people make about the world not
everyone's like you pal
yeah not everyone responds to say it
knock on the door like as friendly as
you do it's like that snake story I'm
too petty I just want revenge that Kate
cast explode and [ __ ] blow off their
face be like frosted with toothpaste cuz
that was fun on April Fool's I used to
like frost cookies with Too Faced and it
looks like frosting yeah because I
thought they could just pick out the
letters then another one like they're
really [ __ ] weak like these are
actual trolls sorry you're such a
hateful person Beth this is not even a
troll that's like her friend I have
never seen a thin person drinking diet
called that's actually my favorite quote
ever that's a Donald Trump quo
nuts he tweeted that did he yeah he did
it's the greatest tweet of all time
oh you know I thought cat did mention
that she sent several cakes to the White
House that people have paid to give to
Donald Trump for she doesn't know if I
don't know why they're eating Allah's
cake in their caddy interesting idea but
you are a terrible Baker your cakes look
like [ __ ] do they do but your idea it
doesn't have the title of Baker she's
just a person cake maker making cakes
ah no professional aspect to this
whatsoever well she puts the home in
homemade but Pinterest fuck-ups exactly
that's exactly what it was a but I will
say this though kudos to you you've made
a good business of some [ __ ] I just
scares me that she if you pay a little
extra she'll hunt this person down for
you lying there address at all that
sucks
that's what I love about it is I will
pay for that service under by Oh like on
Instagram it says troll cakes bakery and
detective agency so you know what the
cool thing is is like what wish you
first when you first said this right and
you're like it's 60 to 80 dollars I was
like 30 to 60 30 to 60 bucks right are
you [ __ ] kidding me
and then you told me she actually finds
him I'm like are you [ __ ] kidding me
that's it that's and it didn't come with
a spy service Yeah right dude but you
can't now okay now I'm kind of picturing
this a little bit so it's like cake goes
to the door right and like thank you to
see the cake go inside and like that
motherfucker's they yeah [ __ ]
like so now I'm gonna go I mean right
it's like that kind of [ __ ] maybe kind
of like the skit that we did a long time
ago
we're like you guys actually found the
trolls no no we blended it with a skit
with with like how or like talking about
how JK sucks now I think another idea of
us get called hater hunters where we
would go and hunt down yeah the hate but
I think the new thing I want to do is
like Chris Hanson's 2020 right but I
want to find a way to track down these
people talking [ __ ] and go over to their
home with the comments I'll print it out
and then if they're underage I'll just
confront their parents but if they're
not
then I can have a talk with them
one-on-one I hope their parents are like
I think it's great our sons in
kindergarten yeah I wrote this [ __ ] it's
like a 60 year old I'm like oh that was
you oh [ __ ] Oh like damn so you find joy
in saying this [ __ ] oh don't feel bad
about budget six-year-old the face 26
year olds not that old
so x2 60 out of your butt they're both
getting 300 kicked in the stomach
you guys are [ __ ] you were just gonna
like read their comment yeah no no no
first it's humiliation but then Vanek
bandha then it escalates oh my god you
get your feelings oh yeah I like when it
goes too far my feelings get really hurt
not me dude I don't give a [ __ ] it's
straight up don't care it's a gun I'm
looking at a white piece of paper
yeah it's like when uh it's funny
because when I started doing auditioning
right and a lot of my friends were like
did it take like about a couple years
sometimes you might not need getting
them from rejection I was like I did the
first one who's bad ii was like I'm good
it's only three people when you do
stand-up it's like a hundred people hate
you if you're not funny
somebody might even come to you after
some video I was one you know you really
are not good yeah yeah it's great
that's why you guys are stand-up
comedians I'm just the person that
people laugh at but I don't know that
I'm funny that's why I get my I get I
get all plot hurt in the comics like I'm
just living life being myself and people
keep laughing at me and it's working
well there's a great cake service you
should maybe you think about cakes hey
you guys want to stock any of us we'll
go ahead down to the description box
below and you can follow us on Instagram
and all kinds of stuff for more videos
you